he wouldn't hesitate to speak the truths
of the king if Auto Hightower was still
a hand you cannot say my queen that your
father would be impartial in this matter
no but he would be partial to me
hey guys Pete here now that is a time
Jump it seems like we jump forward about
10 years based on the ages of Allison's
children it's a little hard to pin it
down exactly because the timeline has
shifted a lot of things around but we've
gone so far into the future that it
wouldn't make sense for the same actors
to portray these characters anymore and
there is a lot in this episode to signal
that things have changed since we last
saw them the fact that this is raniera
giving birth to a child is someone out
of line from her thoughts on pumping out
heirs when she was younger and then
there's the issue of her husband not
being interested in betting her and the
whole thing with Kristen Cole at the end
of the last episode that led to him
switching sides it's a lot to take in
and in some ways it does feel like they
skipped over a lot of the questions that
were hanging over the last episode's
ending however I'll remind you that
we're still essentially in prologue mode
and that there's a lot of setup they
have to do before we get into into the
central conflict in the story and in
episode 6 they got to work on doing that
one thing that is very promising is
right out of the gate I think they
established that Emma Darcy and Olivia
Cook are raniera Targaryen and Allison
Hightower I don't have anything to point
to where the showrunner said that they
hired them first but considering that
these two actors are very important in
carrying the show for its duration it
makes sense to me that they were hired
and then Millie Alcock and Emily Carey
were chosen to play younger versions of
them this opening sequence serves to not
only introduce them but to Showcase
their talents and squash any concerns
about the transition rainer's first shot
plays like a Warner where she struggles
through childbirth and then immediately
receives this request to see the newborn
from the Queen the Way Emma Darcy Cycles
through these emotions effortlessly lets
us know that the role is in good hands
that renera decides to get up and take
the child child to the queen herself
underlines the animosity that has grown
up between these two women in the decade
we didn't see them the first time I
watched this I thought Allison was
actually asking renera to do this rather
than just having someone else bring him
to her but then I realized this is the
princess making a choice to power
through so that her stepmother doesn't
have the chance to pass judgment on the
situation behind her back and again the
actor does a great job of conveying just
how difficult this is and the blood on
the back of her dress and the way it
Trails behind her when they leave the
Queen's Chambers is a nice touch to
drive that home the queen wants to see
the child because her first two didn't
resemble their father or mother and that
raises some questions we'll see later
that their fair skin didn't have dark
hair which leads to everyone thinking
that Harwin strong who will see spends a
lot of time around the princess is
actually the father and you might think
well what does that matter if they're
all at adults and all on board with
what's happening what harm is there in
her taking a lover and having kids
outside of her marriage Lenor claims
them as his own and if she wasn't the
heir to the Iron Throne that would be
fine but because she is this puts
everyone including those children at
Great risk it's one of those things
where you're like I really wanted to
root for you but you're making it really
difficult and they're not even discreet
about it it's true that it shouldn't
have to be that way but you have to keep
in mind that it is that way to keep
people like her family in power she is
one of the primary recipients of a ton
of privilege because that rule is in
place if you're having a hard time
wrapping your head around it then think
about what viserys told his daughter
when they were talking about whether the
rumors about her and Damon at the
brothel were true the truth doesn't
really matter only perception look at
everything that was set into Motion in
the original series based on the idea
that cersei's kids weren't Rob Roberts
the seed is strong remember that and
even though viserys chooses in this case
to totally pretend that perception
doesn't matter we see that it absolutely
does
her third son will be named Joffrey
after lenor's deadlover and he gets the
snarky comment from the queen who tells
him to keep trying and maybe someday
he'll get one that looks like him
tragically we don't get to spend too
much time with Harwin but it's made
clear that he's the father and for what
it's worth they do seem to have real
feelings for each other rather than him
just serving as their surrogate you get
a clear sense that he loves the boys in
the training seat in the yard where he
beats up Kristen and some hint about his
feelings for rhaenyra when his father
calls him out about it as she listens on
in that stairwell the book never really
fleshes out their relationship and I
think it's fine for the show to take the
same route because in the end I suppose
what matters is that their children look
like they could be bastards in a system
where that could call her right to rule
into question her older Sons jacaris AKA
Jace and luceris AKA Luke are on their
way to becoming Dragon Riders we see
them present a dragon egg that they
picked out for their new little brother
and this is part of a tradition that the
book hence started because viserys
wanted to prove to the realm that his
grandchildren weren't the bastards they
appeared to be a dragon egg would be put
in their cradles and when it hatched it
would be proof that they were true
targaryens which doesn't exactly make
sense since his children with Allison
who are also half targs can ride dragons
but that is how the tradition of them
all getting cradle legs started that's
why Jace had a hatchling that he grew up
with in Allison's Second Son Eamon
didn't and we see the former getting to
know his Dragon bare Max and the latter
being upset that he doesn't have a
dragon of his own yet his brother and
half Brothers play a trick on him with
the pink dread and he makes his way
underneath the dragon pit where he's
almost roasted by an older Dragon named
dreamfire it's too much to get into here
but some of them claim dragons that
don't have Riders and some have an egg
in their cradle they it hatches and they
grow up together in this scene you get a
sense of the bonding process with the
hatchling and come away knowing that not
having a dragon is a point of contention
between Eamonn and the other boys
there's a quick introduction to his
sister Helena who we last Saw as an
infant in episode 5. she seems a little
strange she's into bugs and seems very
introspective it's hard to say exactly
what's going on with her from a scene
where she's holding a centipede but she
does appear to be different from her
brothers in some way and her uttering
he'll have to close an eye to herself is
something that you might want to
remember from this scene this could be
hinting that there's more going on with
her but we'll have to wait and see the
kingsguard brings aemon to his mother
and when she finds out about the pig she
goes to tell the saris and you can't
miss the fact that she tries to lay all
the blame on the Valerian boys she takes
things a step further when she tries to
broach the subject of them being bad
bastards something that the King has
already forbidden her from doing in the
past she says to have one child like
that is a mistake to have three is an
insult to the throne two viserys to the
valerians and so on and the part that
really sucks about this is that she's
not really wrong I'm no expert in
genetics in our world let alone in any
fictional world and this is a
complicated situation since Lenor has
Baratheon blood through his mother
rainey's but if we're just thinking
about perception having three boys in a
row that don't favor their black father
would raise questions after Allison
shuts down his argument from his story
about a brown foal being born from a
black mayor that he owned and a Silver
Stallion the king gets down to the truth
of the situation the consequences of
people finding out that Harwin was the
father of his grandsons would be dire if
you think this through he would have to
disinherit her as Lino points out the
Harwood later they would have to kill
him for his crimes under the laws and
then what about the children
in case you don't fully grasp what's
happening Allison summarizes the
situation with Kristen in the next scene
they agree that rhaenyra flaunts the
privilege of her inheritance without
shame and expects everyone around her to
deny the truth of what they plainly see
and beceros has decided to pretend it
isn't happening Kristen goes a little
too far in his rant to establish just
how much he hates rhaenyra and that
gives Allison a chance to explain how
she justifies her actions she needs to
believe that in the end honor and
decency will prevail and they need to
stick to that and to each other this
seems important considering that these
two are moving in the direction of being
characters who are not necessarily wrong
but still manage to be insufferable in
the way they go about things the scene
hints that she sees herself as having
the moral High ground but when she walks
in on her eldest son jerking off in what
looks like the same window tommen walked
out of in season six 6. it stands out
that with her own family she chooses to
ignore some of the things that are going
on instead she brings up that point the
seed that her father planted in her that
if rhaenyra ascends to this Throne her
son's lives will be in danger and as
annoying as the adult version of Allison
is revealing herself to be this does
make the stakes clear at least from her
perspective in her mind people who are
jocking for power will question renera's
claim based on her son's appearances and
that will give her a reason to eliminate
the other possible heirs I.E Allison's
children in the time since we last Saw
Damon grabbing his niece's face at the
wedding Feast he's married Lena Valerian
and they had twins named Bella and Reina
we catch up with them in pentos where
you get to sense that they're
celebrities due to their dragons and
Damon's exploits in the stepstones
there's a fun scene with him and his
wife riding their dragons where we see
just how big Veigar is their daughters
also had cradle Lakes but only Bayless
hatched this means that they have three
dragons in their little family at the
moment and this is worth an offer of a
free mansion and lands from the prince
of pentos if they're willing to relocate
and make themselves a deterrent for the
triarchy the couple is split on this
Damon likes the idea of the simple
transaction of riches in exchange for
the presence of their dragons Lena wants
her children to be raised with their
family according to their Birthright and
would rather have a dragon Rider's end
instead of growing old and fat in the
middle of nowhere after raniera listens
in on Lionel strong complaining to his
son about how his indiscretions with her
matter for their family and how it puts
them at risk we see that while Leonor is
mostly content with their agreement that
leaves him free to hang around the
palace enjoying the Finer Things in life
while partying with his lovers he's
heard about fighting going on in the
stepstones and that has him wanting to
get back out there to spice things up
Rainier won't hear a bit since after
Joffrey's birth she realizes that the
rumors about their parentage are
swirling around their family and in the
end she pulls Rank and commands him as
his princess and heir to the Iron Throne
to remain at her side after Elena
explains to her daughter Reina that
she'll have to follow in her footsteps
and claim her Dragon just as she did
with vegar she goes to tell Damon about
raniera's new son he puts a finer point
on how Harwin being the father is
basically an Open Secret and there is
some interesting stuff going on here
that will be important down the road but
I can't help but feel like they
downplayed the time they spent with Lena
and Harwin based on how this episode
ends she seems to understand that him
not really being a present husband or a
good father has more to do with him and
his feelings about being exiled from his
family rather than her and she says
she's made peace with it at a small
council meeting after they discussed the
situation with the triarchy with her
back against the wall renera tries to
extend an olive branch to the Queen by
suggesting that they marry her Heir Jace
to her daughter Helena she's right in
thinking that this would solve all her
problems and viserys loves the idea but
even before they get interrupted by
rhaenyra's milk leaking and bleeding
through her dress it's clear that
Allison doesn't have any intention of
getting on board with her plan she makes
this plane to the king in the hall
afterward telling him he can follow
through with it when she's cold in her
grave Lionel follows that up by trying
to resign his post as hand of the king
and because he won't say out loud what
the shadow that hangs over his house is
viserys refuses to let him do that
Lionel has been portrayed as the one
person at court that gives the king good
advice regardless of how it might
benefit him personally and when Allison
has dinner with his son Laris they agree
that he's now compromised he can no
longer give unbiased counsel to the king
because his son and illegitimate
grandsons lives could be at stake there
is an interesting parallel baked into
this to when viserys does the exact same
thing with Otto who eventually does come
out with the truth the situation is
different because of the immediate
Stakes that are involved but we see
Allison run with this idea and use that
as a reason why her father should be
reinstated and it's a great touch when
Laris points out that he wouldn't be
impartial either and Allison yells out
no but he would be partial to me I
mentioned how Emma Darcy's opening
sequence really put her stamp on her
character and I think this is where it
happens with Olivia Cook's Allison and I
kind of love the contrast of her big
moment coming at the end of a slow boil
and what that says about the differences
between the characters from there things
ask escalate quickly Laris goes down to
the black cells and offers Mercy to
three criminals for the small price of
having their tongues cut out this felt
somewhat gratuitous I mean I suppose
he's doing this so they can't tell
anyone he's behind what they're about to
do but I also wonder if we're supposed
to have a sense of him just enjoying
being able to do this based on the shots
of his face while he's watching this is
juxtaposed with another birthing scene
gone wrong Lena's Midwife informs Damon
that there's nothing more he can do his
wife's baby won't come he's given the
same opportunity to try the emergency
C-section that viserys had with Emma but
after he finds out she won't survive but
before he gives an answer Lena gets up
and leaves the room to take things into
her own hands she commands her Dragon to
end the pain that she's experiencing and
after some tense moments vegar
eventually does that as Damon looks on
Harwin and Lionel also experience a fire
fiery death laris's tongueless assassin
set a fire in Heron Hall while they're
asleep and that does them in both of
these are heart-wrenching in their own
way and both have huge implications
Damon and Rainier are both lost an
important person in their life viserys
is once again without a hand and it
turns out that Laris is way more crazy
than you might have guessed and doesn't
personally draw the line at kinslaying
rhaenyra also decides to move her family
to Dragonstone and gives lane or
permission to bring his Paramore along
for the ride we see them arrive we see a
quiet moment with viserys in his
Chambers kissing Amy's ring and then we
see Laris tell the queen that he took
the idea of getting her father
reinstated and ran with it I think she's
legitimately surprised that he went as
far as killing his family if anything I
think she was hoping he would do
something that would expose the
parentage of raniera's kids but she did
put it out there that she wanted
something thing to happen and you gotta
love how Laris turned that into a
situation where he made himself
indispensable I think in an episode that
really leaned into her negative traits
were supposed to interpret this last bit
as her not being so far gone and that
she wouldn't expect him to go to these
lanes and it makes for a satisfying
place to end the episode
so yeah I think they mostly pulled off
this big time Jump we missed a lot but
that's how the book is too and so it's
keeping with the spirit of things at the
same time we're getting a clearer
understanding of how a lot of these
things played out and much more
characterization in some cases A decade
is a long time you kind of really hear
that when Lenor talks about doing his
duty and keeping up his end of the
bargain for 10 years families have been
built time has passed but we had enough
of it when they were younger to be able
to follow their progression based on
looking at his head and I couldn't tell
for sure but it looks like viserys's
left arm is completely gone at this
point I would say that his condition is
continuing to get worse but again 10
years is a long time and it didn't
necessarily feel like he would have been
guaranteed to last that long at the end
of episode 5. I know he looks terrible
but has he gotten progressively worse or
did things start to improve after after
Orwell took over as Grand maester it's
hard to say but I guess we can suppose
that mellos died off screen in between
episodes it's not just you every single
character is less sympathetic than they
were the last time we saw them every
living character I guess since all the
ones we lost in this episode were pretty
great they just cleared the board of
people who seem to have their hearts
firmly in the right place in a just
World Lena and the strongs would have
survived the sympathy deficit is a bit
more noticeable with Allison and Kristen
but there are enough bad decisions being
made to go around the kids mostly seem
sympathetic at this point so I would say
just hold on to that while you can
because this is a generational story and
they're all coming up in the same system
that produce their parents and
grandparents and take a close look at
what people are doing because even the
ones that think they're righteous are
way more looking after their own
interests rather than trying to remake
that system I was a little hard on
Rainier earlier and I guess I should
clarify that she is just playing the
hand she was dealt it wouldn't have been
her first choice to marry a gay man in a
situation where she's expected to
reproduce and ensure her own line of
succession that was something that she
had to go along with to hold on to power
that she hasn't yet realized having
passed her children in her position is
still a big risk though and we gotta
look at some of the immediate effects of
that when Jace asked his mother if
Harwin was his father but this is
something that makes her flawed rather
than something that makes her evil I
think some of the discussion I see
around this comes from the Viewpoint
that the rest to Allison's children is
something that Otto cooked up on his own
but you can't forget that rainy saw the
problems of rhaenyra being the heir for
different reasons as did Lionel strong
he could put a lot of the blame on
viserys for not reworking the system to
ensure that she could actually rule
rather than just naming her Heir you
could put blame on Allison for not
accepting her offer to Mary Jace and
Helena and generally undermining her at
court this could have been a solution
that could have helped things but it
doesn't mean you should just let her off
the hook for all the decisions she makes
either viserys's inaction is consistent
with his characterization Allison's
being protective of her children in a
situation where she thinks she's been
pulled into this family where everyone
is against her is consistent with hers
and Ranier is thinking she should be
able to do whatever she wants because
she was born a Targaryen princess is
consistent with hers this episode made
me think about a quote from George R.R
Martin I read in one of the first
articles that came out about the show
where he's talking about the story being
like a Shakespearean tragedy he told the
interviewer there's no Arya a character
everybody's going to love they're all
flawed they're all human they do good
things they do bad things they're driven
by lust for power jealousy Old Wounds
just like human beings just like I wrote
them and what what I liked about this
episode is that we've arrived at the
point where it's clear that none of
these characters are of the type you can
root for you can choose sides and people
will but none of the main characters are
without things that you'll have to
overlook to do that for me it doesn't
really matter if I like them or where
they land on the Imagine scale of
morality as long as what they're doing
makes sense for the characters they've
been presented as and now that we've
reached this point things can really
take off and I think that's a great
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about this
episode and where things will go if you
haven't read the book and if you have
what did you think about the way things
are playing out they definitely move
some things around the timeline here and
it feels like a choice not to spend too
much time on Harwin and Lena so if you
want to talk book spoilers that's fine
just please add a couple line breaks put
them below the fold so that people won't
see them unless they want to please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon